all right y'all I want to close out with
one last story that I hope will bring
you a huge smile this is what I'm
liking earlier this hour we met Lacy
who's hanging out on our wfir VIP lounge
right now and is going to come to Vegas
right yeah she's an elementary school
educator who also happens to be a crazy
powerful vocalist like insane we love
shining a light on musical Talent of all
ages here in all genres of music and
just look at this seven-year-old drummer
we discovered on Tik Tok
[Music]
I don't know if we discovered but we
found um that's Ryder and he doesn't
just play with kid y Ryder has his very
own band called Ryder and the Masters
made up of all grown-ups and they play
some of LA's most iconic Vos seriously
and we it's amazing we have Ryder and
his dad Jason on the line now watching
on NBC Los Angeles what's up
Ryder up
Kelly oh my God you're so rock and roll
man all right so Jason how did you
discover writer's talent I mean from
right away he was all about the music
and um you know we didn't realize he was
an actual musician until he was about
two and he was playing drums on his
height chair he played a very
recognizable Ramone song and then within
like the week we got a drum kit that's
incredible man let's see a little more
of Rider in
[Music]
action like what ryer you are so cool oh
my gosh like what do you love about
drumming well I what I love about
drumming is like I love how it just like
like uh like it just comes from your
heart you know it just beats you up and
and that and that's what it gives you
like the headbangs you know and it just
like it's crazy oh my gosh I cannot wait
to see where your life is head of you
are so so cool oh my gosh well y'all
have a big gig next week right oh yeah
uh Ryder B and the Masters are playing
at the whiskey of goo on Sunset
bullart oh my gosh all the posters back
there yeah AB absolutely Ryder rock and
roll little one oh my gosh thank you so
much Ryder and thank you Jason youall
have such a great time at the whiskey
I'm liking your post right now right oh
I love that and I'm actually uh so and
I'm actually recording a live album
there my first album live album oh my
God that is so incredible we're going to
have to get you to play at some point
Ryder You're like I'm going to need to
feel that that talent in person all
right well that's not all actually our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to RAS pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate those
fearlessly pursuing music Just Like You
Rockstar so they're going to give you
$1,000 to help
out oh my gosh thank you Ryder thank you
Jason thank you to all our guests this
our Leslie johnes Ian summerer Moya Cole
Lacy and lawren there you have a great D
it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home